Do you have a witness protection
program?
Can you provide me with a couple of big
guys?
I can keep an eye on me after that.
Uh,
you know,
I,
I honestly don't.
I think one has to say honestly that for
anyone to go into the poetry business,
one has to respect the fact that they're
trying to do at all,
you know,
so I,
I would just,
I think it'd be,
I wouldn't be interested in,
um,
I'm mean,
apart from the fact that you know,
it,
it would not be politically smart.
Have someone who has a certain,
you know,
as an editor of the New Yorker,
probably inappropriate for me to say I
hit so and so.
The fact of the matter is that there is
no one I had.
I'm really open to the.
I'm really open to the possibility that
a great poem will come down the pike
from anywhere.
I really am innocent and it's at a,
it's a fact of life that they do,
that they do and it's a fact of life
that,
for example,
writers,
um,
who often may not have been able to,
you know,
produce simply adding work.
Actually one day will,
uh,
so no one and that goes from students.
No one does not write off anyone and
that's largely because,
apart from anything else
on a good day,
ideally it's not even they're doing,
it's not the doing of the person when
the only when the person I deeply,
deeply believe only when the person has
given herself or himself over to the
idea that they're in part and writing a
poem is actually quite small,
but they have to apply for something
beyond themselves to happen.
And we know that experience.
We know that experience from,
you know,
even if we're reading a letter we wrote
six months ago,
nevermind,
um,
know a paper one road at college and you
look at it new thing,
who wrote that?
Did I write that now?
Couldn't have,
couldn't have been me who wrote there.
That's,
you know,
too smart.
It's too good.
It's due to flirt to whatever,
and it's that sense actually,
that one is taken over by something
ideally that,
uh,
that one must never lose sight of.
So I,
you know,
I don't,
I really,
I,
I'm,
I'm interested in poetry and many,
many,
many manifestations,
many manifestations.
So I,
I really don't.
Just thinking here,
honestly,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't be done too much.